[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام الى متى يتشدق
نظام بشار الاسد بحمايه الاقليات كما لو
ان وجود الاقليات في سوريا من منجزات
الحركه التصحيحيه
الم يتسبب النظام بتهجير اكثر من مليون
وثلاثمائه الف مسيحي
الات قصف قوات الاسد الاماكن المقدسه في
معلولا المسيحيه يوميا الم يضطر حوالي نصف
الدروس خاصه للشباب الى الهجره بسبب القهر
والفقر
الم يماطل نظام الاسد عشرات السنين في
بناء ضريح لقائد الثوره السوريه الكبرى
سلطان باشا الاطرش
الم يمنع الدروز حتى من الاحتفال بذكرى
الباشا لم تقم وزاره الاعلام السوريه بحرق
ارشيف سلطان الاطرش كاملا
الم يصل احتقار النظام للدروز بان عوض
عائلات الذين قضوا في الاحداث الجاريه ب
عن ستين عن كل شهيد الم يعمد الى تفجير
المناطق الاسماعيليه عندما بدات تشارك في
الثوره الم يحرم الاكراد من ابسط حقوقهم
المدنيه الم يجعل العلويين او من العلويين
وقودا ل معركته الوحشيه للبقاء في السلطه
العلوي في القبر والاس في القصر الا يعيش
العلويون في فقر مدقع
لكن في المقابل الا يكفي ان نظام علماني
ولا يمكن ان يصعد الاقليات على اساس عقدي
الم يصل ابناء الاقليات الى الاعلى او
اعلى المراتب في الدوله الم يكن وزير
الدفاع السابق مسيحيا اليس اشهر ضابط
يعتمد عليه النظام في قمع الثوره درزيا
اليس وزير المصالحه الوطنيه اسماعيل يا
الم يكن اشهر الشخصيات الدينيه المقربه من
النظام كرديه الم يهاجر الكثير من الدروز
والمسيحيين طوعيا لاغراض اقتصاديه
اليس من الاجحاف
المخابرات العسكريه في السويداء بخطف شباب
الدروز لايقاع الفتنه مع اهل درعا الا
يشكل النظام العلماني ضمانا للاقليات في
ظل التطرف الديني المتصاعد في المنطقه
اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره على
الباحث والمعارضه السوري ماهر شرف الدين
من جبل العرب وعلى عضو مجلس الشعب السوري
والكاتب شريفه هادي نبدا النقاش بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك مرات الاخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل تعتقد ان النظام السوري يتاجر
بالاقليات صوت على صفحه الاتجاه المعاكس
سبعه عشر الفا ومائتين وثلاثه وتسعين شخصا
اربعه وتسعون فاصله واحد نعم النظام يتاجر
بالاقليات خمسه فاصله تسعه لا
ما شرف الدين لو بدات معك في هذه النتيجه
ما الذي يجعل يعني هذه الشريحه الهائله
بصراحه يعني بمستويات التصويت اربعه
وتسعين فاصله واحد يعتقدون ان النظام
السوري
يتاجر بالاقليات في الوقت نفسه نسمع شخصا
ومثل وزير الخارجيه الروسي لافروف يقول
دائما النظام العلماني السوري هو حامي
الاقليات الضمان الاقليات كيف ترد ساجيبك
بطريقه علميه اه لدينا ثلاث اقليات في
سوريا يدعي النظام بانه يقوم بحمايتها
مسيحيون الدروز الاسماعيليون الان ساعطي
كل اقليه كيف كان حالها قبل مجيء النظام
وكيف صار حالها بعد مجيء النظام سابدا
بالدروس الدروز قبل ما قبل مجيء النظام
ايام البعض السنه حصل الدروز على اربع
وزارات الدفاع اربع وزراء الدفاع اول وزير
العمل
الباب والسنه
اربع وزراء الدفاع حتى ما يكون كلا من هيك
اول وزير الدفاع عبد الغفار ثاني وزير
الدفاع حسنا طرف ثالث وزير الدفاع عادل
ارسلان ورابع وزير الدفاع حمد عبيد اربع
وزراء الدفاع ايضا حصل الدروز على منصب
رئيس اركان الجيش السوري في الخمسينيات
كله يعلم انه رئيس اركان الجيش السوري كان
الجنرال الدرزي الشهير شركه الشكيك بل
اكثر من ذلك
البعض السنه
وصلوا الى منصب القائد العام للجيش
والقوات المسلحه
هل تعلم انه سنه 1963 عندما حصل انقلاب
البعث كان القائد العام للجيش والقوات
المسلحه جنرال درزي اسمه اللواء عبد
الكريم زهر الدين وقد اعتقل الانقلابيون
ووضعوه في السجن وبعدها يصرحوا هذا
بالعسكر يا سيدي اكثر من ذلك كانت كتله
ضباط ضباط الدروس في الجيش انذاك اقوى
قتله على الاطلاق الجيش السوري لماذا ليست
مصادفه ليست عفو الخاطر لانه الاكثريه
السنيه وطنيه سنيه انذاك قدرت للدروز
موقفهم ودفاعهم عن سوريا ضد الاحتلال
الفرنسي فلذلك فلذلك اه يعني عطت هم
مقدمتهم الى الواجهه سهلت لهم الوصول الى
مقدمه ال اه الجيش طوال عمر من بني معروف
هم سيد سوريا المسؤول من ايام ابراهيم
باشا المصري لايام اه مائه معركه مع
الاستعمار العثماني معارك مع الاستعمار
الفرنسي لذلك الوطنيه السنيه فهمه ذلك ف
قدرت للدروس فقد متهم الى مقدمه الجيش هذا
بالعسكر بالسياسه يكفي ان الوقت اقول لك
سنه الف وتسعمائه وثمانيه واربعين تم
تكليف الشخصيه الدرزيه الوطنيه مشهوره
عادل الاسلام تم تكليف بتشكيل الحكومه
سوريا انذاك لم يستطع عادل ارسنال تشكيل
الحكومه بسبب بتعقيدات الوضع السياسي ولان
اه كانت ايام حكم انقلاب حسني الزعيم
فلذلك اه لذلك لو حدث كان يمكن ان يحدث لو
حدث ذلك كنت اليوم ساقول لك يا دكتور فيصل
انه الف وتسعمائه وثمانيه واربعين حكمت
سوريا شخصيه وطنيه درزيه اسمها عاد
الارسال السياسي والعسكري الا جاء النظام
حافظ السجين نظام حامي الاقليات ماذا فعل
سنه الف وتسعمائه وسته وستين
حصلت اكبر حمله تسريع في تاريخ الجيش
السوري ثلاث مائه ضابط الدرزي من اعلى
الرتب الى ادناها تم تسريحهم الدرزيه صارت
الراحه صراحه جديد وحافظ الاسد وعندما
ارادت سليم حاطوم الرد على هذا الانقلاب
بانقلاب اه قبض العشرين سنه سبعه وستين
وقتلوا عدم نشر اعدام
اه فقط عينيه
اظهر كلما الدروس
في جسد سليم حاطوم الان اه بعد هذه
التصفيه لم يعد الدرزي يحلم بالوصول الى
اي رتبه وقد تم تعميم يا سيدي طول خمسين
سنه بعد الله على اصابع يدي الواحد ين كم
واحد وصل الى رتبه اللواء القليله جدا
العاقل هو بطل بطل تحرير اه عمليه مرصد
تحرير مصر جبل الشيخ وصلت عميد بعدين شو
طالعه تقاعد لذلك اليوم لذلك اليوم اضعف
مشاركه في الجيش السوري هي مشاركه الضباط
الدروز ولا لانه لا مع نواصل ارجو اه اه
لذلك اضعف مشاركه لما بلشت الاحداث الموصل
عصام زهر الدين جاء النظام اراد ان يضع
شخصيه دوليه في الواجهه كما اتى به
المسكين داود راجحه
مسيحي دور لم تجد اي شخصيه درزيه كبيره في
الجهات ضابط شبه مغمور كان قائد الكتيبه
بعدين صاروا
جابوا حطوا في الواجهه ليقول للسنه ان
الدروز هم من يقتلون كم ها هي التقنيه
نفسها اللي استخدمها اه
بالاعلام زهر الدين يدمر حاله بدر الدين
دين عسر الدين
زهر الدين سوبر مان سوبر مان يقاتل في كل
مكان
[موسيقى]
كيف اولا مقدم تلك التي قدمتها والبرنامج
الافتراضي هذا رايك ولو عرضته على طفل
عندنا في الحاره رفض ما قلته
اولا لم يشهد تاريخ سوريا لا قديم ولا
حديث موضوع طائفي رغم ان سوريا بلد يعيش
فيها امرين الامر الاول هو القوميات العرب
والكرد وغيرهم من القوميات سوريا النقطه
الثانيه هي الاسلام والمسيحيين واليهود ين
ولم تتعامل سوريا على مر التاريخ معامله
الطوائف هذا امر يعرفه كل سوري وانا اسالك
الان يعني السوريين بيعرفوا انه العلويين
مش مفضلين بسوريا العناوين الاقليه لكنهم
اكثريه
يعني
اولا هذا التاريخ الممتد منذ بدايه نشات
سوريا حتى الان لم يعرف شيء اسمه طائفيه
ولا حتى شيء اسمه اديان الان رغم الازمه
التي اشتدت على سوريا هناك من اتى من
الخارج ل يحرض ويقول هذا على وهذا الدرجه
نحن كنا ندرس في المدرسه ولا نعرف الطالب
المسيحي من الطالب المسلم وانت تخرجت من
جامعه دمشق ولما يسالك احد ما هي الاديان
لسبب بسيط ان اخرهم السوريين هو موضوع
الديانات لان كل سوري ملتزم وهو مسيحي نحن
في سوريا اثنين وعشرين مليون مسيحي واثنين
وعشرين مليون درزيه اثنين وعشرين مليون
علوي واثنين وعشرين مليون اسماعيل
انا برايي ليس هناك تفرقه وللتاكيد على ما
تفضل به ضيفي في الازمه الان الحاليه توجه
بشكل طبيعي اه اللواء داوود راجحه العماد
داوود راجحه الى منصب وزير الدفاع لو كان
النظام طائفيا او لو كان النظام يتعامل
على شكل طائفي لما وصلت لا دوله ولا عصام
زهر الدين الامر الثاني سوريا بلد التعايش
فيها كل المواطنين وكل جهده اما اليوم
نريد ان نحرر على موضوع طائفي نقول فلان
كذا وفلان كذا انا اقول لك حتى هذه اللحظه
ما اللعب على الوتر الطائفي لم يستطيع ان
ينجح والدليل على كلامي الاف العائلات
التي هربت من حلب هربت الى طرطوس
واللاذقيه والاف العائلات التي هربت من
ذرعا هربت الى طرطوس واللاذقيه هذا يؤكد
لك ان التعامل في سوريا ليست عاملا طائفيه
على اساس دوله ما بتتدخل بس جاوبني على
نقطه ما بدي ادخل بالمره يقول لك الرجل
النظام قدم نفسه دائما على انه حاملا قل
يا الطرف الاخر يقول لك هذا النظام لم
يحمل اقليات هذا النظام يحتمي بالاقليات
وهو اكثر من اساء للاقليه دروز ومسيحيين و
اسماعيليين وافرادا وعلويين هذا اللي بدي
جواب عليه
انا لست
استقر حزب البعث نشا على قاعده انها امه
عربيه واحده ذات رساله خالده والا في حزب
البعث ميشيل عفلق المسيحي واخر
فكيف يكون حزب البعث وهو الحزب الحاكم في
سوريا كيف يكون كيف يكون طائفي وهو الذي
يدافع عن الامه العربيه ويكسر الحدود بين
كل الامه فكيف له النظام او الحزب كيف له
ان يكون طائفيا وهو يدعو الى توحيد الامه
باكملها من اليمن الى الى الى السودان الى
من اسهل ما يكون انك ترفع شعار قومي كبير
و تختبئ بعده بعده تحكم به من ثقب الابره
بالطائفيه يعني هذا
قومي قومي
المسيحيون في سوريا والاخوه جبل العرب
الدروز والاسماعيليون اعطيني مثال واحد
الان على شاشه الجزيره قبل الازمه والازمه
بالازمه على اقتتال طائفي بين كل هذه
اثنين هل شاهدتها منطقه في سوريا بني فيها
ال الدوله مكان غير مكان يعني بمعنى هل
بلد الدوله الجامعات لا تقيم في دمشق وحلب
ودرعا البلد الدوله ومؤسساتها في محافظه
واحده هل بلد الدوله الجيش في محاكمه ايضا
هذا الجيش العربي السوري الذي يقاتل مع
احترامي ل ل ضيفك الكريم اليس هو من كل
الطوائف السوريه وهو يقاتل على امتداد
تقول لي انه الجيش السوري جيش وطني جيش
وطني بامتياز
اخر احصائيه عملها جمال خاشقجي الحرف
والكذا هناك الف ومائه وستين ضابط امير في
الجيش السوري طلع من الف ومائه
لو كان قائد الجيش
يا اخي
يعني هذا الموضوع يجب ان
هذا الرجل
المنطق اعطت اسماء من المسيحيين
دروس من ال ال التشكيله الدوله السوريه
كلياتها انه هذه الدوله السوريه بالاصل
توجهها قومي لا يمكن ان تحكم ب بهذا
الاطار اللي
اقيمت هذه الاسماء يا اخي
وبعد خمس اشهر من بدايه الازمه حطوا امام
ال بالواجهه لحتى يقال انه هذا ضابط مسيحي
هو وزير الدفاع وهذا القتل نفس الشيء يعني
دكتور لا
المسيحيين بدي احكي لك عن المسيحيين
المسيحيين اه قبل مجيء النظام وصل وصلوا
الى كل المناصب في الدوله باستثناء منصب
واحد و منصب رئاسه الجمهوريه وكان فارس
خوري الشخصيه الوطنيه المسيحيه المشهوره
ان يصل الى منصب رئاسه الجمهوريه لكن
تعقيدات الوضع انذاك لم تسمع قبل النظام
قبل النظام كانوا وصلوا الرئيس ورئيس مجلس
وزراء كل الادارات كل كذا كانت اكبر نسبه
اه وظائف بالدوله الوظائف التقنيه
والاداريه كانت المسيحيين اللي بيقرا
تاريخ سوريا بيعرف ذلك ليش لانه الطائفه
المسيحيه اه نسبه الثقافه والتعليم فيها
اعلى عندما جاء حافظ الاسد اول شيء هذه
النسبه اعطيت امين بلا اخواننا واحب ان ا
العلويين ثاني شيء كان الوزير كان فارس
خوري كان يحكم سوريا هو رئيس الوزراء كان
الوزير مثلا وزير صحه مسيحي يحكم وزارته
لما بعد ما تحول المسيحيين وبقيت الطوائف
الى ديكور صار عندك مثلا انت وزير صحه
والنقل المسيحي بطوله ضابط امن علوي اقسم
بالله اقوى منه لهذا
بيقولوا اذا شو فيه بيعملوا شاي هو على
وهذه
انا قدمت انا قدمت عسكري الجيش السوري اه
اذا فيه عارف علوي مع احترامي محطه
العناوين الضابط ما بيسترجوا يا رجل انا
لا احكي لك شغله مره بمدرستي عشقه فتاه
علويه اكثر من ذلك وتكتب تنشا بيحافظ
اسمها ما نقول عليها مثلا بيشيروا حتى يتم
فيها بالفرصه بال شو اسمه بعد ساعه
المشرف على المخابرات اخذنا اتصور لاي لاي
درجه افسد المجتمع انه نحنا مراهقين على
الدراسه قلبك تملك مائتين شعر تجي بين ال
مش بين المخابرات انا ما عم لهم العلويه
انا اقول العلويين وقعوا في فخ السلطه
السلطه الذي حفره لو حافظ الاسد او من قبل
صلاح الجديد هذا بس لحظه انا بتحكي عن
شغله اه وقت مجزره داريا مشهوره مجزره
ماذا عن المسيحيه كيف النظام يشتغل
المجزره الداعيه تصور عندك في التلفزيون
السوري يمكن الفين مذيع ومذيعه واحده
اسمها مش اسمها مش العازل يعني اي واحد ب
يسمعها هويتها الطائفيين بين انه هي
مسيحيه وحطه وهي مبسوطه بحاله طالعه بتغطي
المجزره يعني ها هي الاساليب المسيحيين
كانوا حكام كانوا جزء اصلي من الحكم قبل
النظام اه بعد ما حافظ ساتحول والديكور
بعد اندلاع الثوره صاروا ودائع غربيه صار
النظام الفوضى الغرب عليه ان هناك وداع
بعدين اليوم تحولوا الى
انا اول شيء
الشاعر اللي
هذا الموضوع
اللي عليه مباشره
سوريا على مدار تاريخه على مدار تاريخه لم
تعرف الحالات الطائفيه و راح اعطيك الادله
في الحركه التصحيحيه منذ الحركه التصحيحيه
حتى هذه اللحظه كيف كان يعيش المسيحيين
والدروز والاسماعيليون اسمح لي تعرف كنيسه
بسوريا فيه فيه سبعمائه كنيسه بسوريا في
في سبعطاشر الف جامع في اه اضرحه للاخوه
الاسماعيليه في اطرح على الاخوه الدروز هل
سمعت يوم من الايام ان النظام قام بهدم
جامعا وكنيسه على الاطلاق بل اكثر من ذلك
اكثر من ذلك
وحتى السيد الرئيس بشار الاسد كان يقوم
بزيارات للعائلات المسيحيه و للطوائف
المسيحيه في اعيادها وكذلك الاسلامي
ثلاثه هل يا دكتور فيصل تستطيع او يستطيع
انسان ان ينكر ان المسيحي كان والمسلم بكل
طوائفهم كان يقوم بتاديه الشعائر
وال والمعتقدات وكل شيء بحريه تامه هل كان
يطلب من الحكومه السوريه اشاده اي بناء
لجامعه او كنيسه لا يقدم لنا هذا يؤكد لك
ان الحكومه السوريه لا تتعامل بشكل طائفي
النقطه الثانيه النقطه الثانيه التي اريد
ان اقوله الرئيس بشار الاسد
تزوج زوجته السيده اسماء الاسد بعد ان سلم
الحكومه لو كان رئيس الدوله ينظر الى
الامور بمنظار طائفي هل تزوج امراه من
الطائفه الثانيه
اولا اولا انا بدي اعطيك حقائق
الباحث المسيحي المعروف جورج كذا لديه بحث
بالورقه والقلم واحد زائد واحد يساوي
اثنين عدد المسيحيين في سوريا عندما جاء
حافظ الاسد الى السلطه عام الف وتسعمائه
وسبعين كانوا يشكلون سته عشر في المائه من
الشعب السوري عددهم بالضبط مليون ونصف
مسيحي مليون ونصف المليون مسيحي
الهجره المسيحيه الكبرى الاولى حدثت في
عهد حافظ الاسد كمان خرج من سوريا نصف
مليون مسيحي خرجوا من سوريا في الدقيقه
كانوا مليون ونصف بالمائه في عهد بشار
الاسد منذ ان جاء بشار الاسد من الفين من
الفين وحتى الان خرج من سوريا نصف اكثر من
نصف مليون اكثر من نصف مليون مسيحي هل
تعلم كم بقى من المسيحيين في سوريا الان
بعد ان كان وسطاش بالمائه عدد المسيحيين
في سوريا في ال في في في النظام الذي
يتشدق بحمايه الاقليات مائتين الف مسيحي
من اصل هذه احصائيه
الاحصائيه مائه بالمائه
انا اقول لك قبل ان اتي وصلت الى وزاره
الاوقاف ووصلت الى بعض المراكز في سوريا
عن عدد المسيحيين في سوريا عدد المسيحيين
في سوريا الان مليون مسيحي
الهجره التي يهاجر ها الاخوه المسيحيين
ليس كانت
المسيحيين لديهم تصور للحياه تختلف عن
تصور المسلم هو يحب ان يتاجر ان يسافر ان
يفتح افق للعمل اثنين يعني يعني ممكن ممكن
عندما لم تكن حافظ
عندما اتى الرئيس حافظ الاسد وكان في
لقاؤه الاخير مع كمال جنبلاط قبل
قال
قال الرئيس حافظ الاسد كمال جنبلاط وكان
الخلاف بينهما
بتهجير المسيحيين اللبنانيين ولن اسمح ان
يكون اسرائيل ان تكون اسرائيل حضنا
للمسيحيين انكم تدفعون المسيحيين للهجره
تحت ضربوا ل والعنف هذا الكلام
كلام جميل جدا جميل جدا
النظام السوري
في سوريا
بدي اسالك قبل ما هذا نقطه واحده واعطى كل
ده ملكي يوسف كوريا
في سجون الاسد منذ سته منذ سته وثلاثين
عاما وهو من الطائفه او من الاقليه
السريانيه مسيحي اقدم سجين سياسي في
العالم
والمسلمين
انت تقول النظام هجر ولا يعترف بالمسيحيين
طيب شكرا كوريا مستشار الرئيس الاسد لاكثر
من عشرين عاما
الياس مراد رئيس اتحاد الصحفيين مسيحي
مسيحي فائده مجلس الشعب
الرجل الرجل سال اسئله واجابات
الارقام اللي حقيقه ولا سوق السؤال الثاني
انه انت شو كل المسيحيه
اسماعيليه يخبروا انه هل تعلم انه اول اول
طائفي تظاهرت اول مدينه تظاهره ضد الحركه
الصحيه الاسماعيليين اهل الاسلاميه الف
وتسعمائه وسبعين والمعلومات شعبه الحزب
موقفه الاسلاميه الى ثلاثه اشهر لذلك حافظ
الاسد اول شيء اه يعني
حرمه من استقرار اه مياه نهر الفرات بعدين
اوقف كانت عمليه الاصلاح الزراعي اوقف
انهم ليس بس انا بدي اقول شغله بمساله
عندما عندما شاركوا في الثوره ماذا عن
اليوم في مائتين من تونس ابو ظبي
اسماعيليين في السجن و هامتين رقم مائتين
حوالي مائتين هو كبير بالنسبه للطائفه
تعدادها قليل بس لحظه يادكتور هناك معادله
عجيبه بالنسبه بين النظام الاقليات خصوصا
الدروز
كل ما وقع النظام في ازمه وقع في حب
الدروز كل ما وقع النظام في ورطه وقع في
غرام الدروز بيصير الحب كت كت منه اليوم
عم بيحقق السلطان
الفيلم
هل تعلم بان النظام منع اقامه ضريح سلطان
لاكثر من عشرين سنه سلطان الاطرش اللي هو
الثوره السوريه الكبرى كامه عربيه في
القرن العشرين ضريح التصور لم يسمح النظام
عفوا دكتور لم يسمح باقامه الضريح الا بعد
الفين وخمسين عندما حدث زلزال اغتيال
الحريري وعندما طرد الجيش النظام من لبنان
انذاك
ال النظافه لذلك سمح ببناء
انه يعني يعني
سلطان الاطرش ظلوا ضريح
الضريح مختلف هل تعلم انه النظام يمنع
يمنع طوال عقود الاحتفال بذكرى السلطان
فيه اكثر من 200 شاب يمكن مجهولين بين
سوريا
وبسبب مشاركتهم بالاحتفال في ممنوعه تحتفل
بذكرى وفاه سلطان هذا تعلم انه سنه الف
وتسعمائه وتسعه وتسعين بالسويد صدر تعميم
التجاره ت جالس ويدي عم بيسمعوني بيعرفوا
صدر تعميم بمنع كان تسويه يبيعوا صواني
نحاسيه منقوش عليها صوره السلطان من عام
الف وتسعمائه وتسعه وتسعين قال المسموح بس
وان الحسين مرسوم عليها صوره ال حافظ
الاسد لانه حافظ الاسد ناقص واني انا يا
دكتور عشره طفولتي بالشدادي منطقه الحسكه
مره حضرنا اه احتفال بمناسبه عيد الجلاء
طلع الخطيب قال صالح صالح في غير مناسبه
عيد الجلاء الخطيب الثاني ماذا قال حرفيا
قال قائد الثوره السوريه الكبرى صالح
الحاليه كان قاعد حدي زميله بالمدرسه
المتعصب لسلطان قال لي يا رجل اذا
الحالي هو قائد الثوره السوريه الكبرى شو
كان يعمل تقتل وكان يمسك على تعلم انه عدد
المقيمين خارج السويدي اكبر من عدد
المقيمين داخل السودان في اربعمائه الف
واربعمائه الف مهاجر او لا اربعمائه الف
مهاجر انا اليوم بدي اقول معلومه وانا
مسؤوله عن ها المعلومه من اخذت من
الناشطين دروس في فنزويلا تقوى المعلومه
بتتعلق ب ازدياد نسبه تجاره الدروز بعد
سنه الالفين بعد سنه الالفين بس مشان
المشاهدين يعرفوا سنه الالفين حدثت او
لانتفاضه في وجه حكم بشار الاسد بالسويد
دفعت السويد واحده واربعين شهيدا وثلاث
مائه وثلاث مائه جريح المهم اه بعد تلك
الانتفاضه اللي قمعت بالدبابات والى اخره
ازدادت وزيره يعني كان يهاجر شاب على
فنزويلا صاروا يهاجروا بعد الانتفاضه عشره
المعلومه تقول انه النظام السوري بسنه
الالفين الشهير نوصل للحكم الف وتسعمائه
وتسعه وتسعين سنه الالفين النظام الحكومه
السوريه طلبت من تشافيز تسهيل هجره الدروز
لذلك صار اذا ما قدم 41 درجه واحد مسيحي
واحد على وعد بياخذوا ال ال فنزويلا
بتسهل
للتفريق الجبل انا اقول ذلك عفوا
انا اقول ذلك وانا مستعد المعلومه تبين
غير دقيقه انا اعتذر عنها لكن راح نحاول
ان الناشطين الدروس بين بين ايدي الجبهه
ليعرفوا هل الجبل و مين ومين حاول
هي النقطه هذه النقطه
الان ان ادخل في قرى السويدان واثنين من
السيدات لم تجد شابا في السويداء كلها
جائزه خطيره وبتهم السويدي ليش ما طلعت
وما فيها الشباب طيب
عدد الدروس في سوريا ستمائه الف خمسمائه
الف هل يا استاذ شريف دقيقه في مائتين الف
بامريكا اللاتينيه ومائه وخمسين الف
بالخليج لماذا هاجر نصف الدروس من الفقر
من الظهر سيدي
وداعا يا حبيبتي نشهدها يا زنبقه ما تغيب
عن
اولا ما تفضل بالاستاذ عن موضوع السلطان
باشا لصالحنا معلومات المحافظه الاسد هو
الذي اوعز باقامه الضريح
بينما الضريح هو المشهد يعني ناس دوره مثل
العظماء
وخمسه
بامر من الرئيس
لم تهتم الدوله
اهتمت الدوله الاتفاقيه والاخوه في
له مكانه عند كل عند السوريه وليست
يحترمه ويحترمها وله مكانه خاصه
دقيقه بس دقيقه طيب هل تعلم ان وزاره
الاعلام السوريه دمرت
الاحتفال
تقول شيء لا تعرف هناك توجهات من الرئيس
حافظ الاسد ومن الرئيس بشار الاسد
بالاحتفال بذكرى سلطان باشا
الهجره اهل الجبل من الزمن القديم
وقبل الرئيس بشار الاسد الاخوه في جبل
العرب الامر
الحوار بين الرئيس بشار الاسد
ان شاء الله في الايام القادمه
باختصار
دقيقه كيف عليها المسيحيين والدروس بجمله
واحده يا اخي المسيحيين وضع مختلف عنده
الدروس صارت تجربتهم منهجيه بعد يا دكتور
تقنيات استعمار
بدي اقول شغله انا هنا الجامعه نحنا اما
الشهيد اعجابه وبعثوا
كاميرات التلفزيون تصور امام احد القتلى
حمله قرون المعز بدي اقول لاهل الجبل نحنا
اما الشهيد عندنا بتصور مع بندقيه ابناء
السوريه
[موسيقى]
الكلمه الثاني واعيد ان عدد
الماعز التي الضيوف
جبل العرب له كل احترام وتقدير
الاقليات
كمان هلا اولا انتفاضه خرجت ضد حكم بشار
الاسد كانت يدا واحده
[تصفيق]
41 شوف شو عمل حصلت مجزره امام مستشفى
السويدي قام احد العرفاء فتح النار على
المتظاهرين
قتل وجرح العشرات ماذا قال لام لاهل
السودان قال ان سربوا لهم انه اه الذي فتح
النار هو عريف سني من حمله لما دخلت
الدبابات من نظام طرد سنه الالفين وحتى
العلم نزل يعني ما ما نحكي اكثر من هيك
دخلت الدبابات حصلت مجزره ماذا قالوا الى
بعض شيوخ السويديه الامن قانون الذي ادار
عمليه دخول الدبابات
سني من حوران يعني اطلع اللي قتلوا الدروز
يعني بمعنى يا دكتور
ماذا قال لهم قالوا لهم الدروس يحرقون
مساجد بطلوا البدو قتلوا ال بدو بدو
وهذا ما
عندك بعدد الدروز الذين قتلوا في سجون
النظام بالتعليم
بعد من مامون نوفل
اه من القريه
رومان
في سجون النظام
تناقش امر بتفصيلات جزئيه اولا ما يتحدث
به ضيفنا هو كان صراع حول موضوع
[موسيقى]
بين انا بكره بين الاخوه في جبل العرب واه
حاضر فيما بعد على موضوع المصالحه في هذا
الامر وتم تسويه الوضع على موضوع مراعي
هذه النقطه نظام قتل ولا شيء الامر الثاني
واربعين انتم انتم تتحدثون عن حلقه عن
الطائفيه انا لا
يعني مثلا عندما يكون الانسان طائفي يكون
طائفي في كل المجالات يعني انا اه اول شيء
نجاح العطار زعيم الاخوان المسلمين وهي
نائبه رئيس الجمهوريه لو كان النظام يريد
ان ينتقم او يتعامل على اساس طائفي ما فيه
حدا بيقدر يجيب نائب رئيس جمهوريه كان
يجيب غير هذا يؤكد ان النظام الدولي بمعنى
تتعامل مع انه نجاح العطار نائب رئيس
جمهوريه شيء على نوعين رئيس الجمهوريه
وزير الثقافه ورئيس الجمهوريه عنده
صلاحيات
الموضوع
تحدث
تحدث الرجل عن عن عن المحاولات اللي حاول
ها النظام الاساسيين والتحريض بين جبل
العرب هل تعلم الان حسين قائد كتيبه
المؤسسه العظمى كل الصواريخ والهاون الذي
يسقط فوق منطقه الدروز في جرمانا
والمسيحيين من عند النظام هو الذي يفجر
وهو الذي يطلق الاداره
التابع
الارهابيون
الذين ذهبوا الى عبره الذين احتجزوا
الدرزي والعلوي المسيحي والسني بدؤوا
بقتال الجميع وقتل الجميع ورم يوم من
التوافق الاخيره النظام فعلا يتعامل مع
المواطنين سواحله
لها على الجميع لسبب بسيط ان هذا النظام
علماني
انا انه هذا النظام لن يتعامل مع الاقليات
على
اساس ديني او اساس على الاقل العلماني
انا اتفق معه انه هو نظام المحاصصه ابدا
لانه هو النظام الطائفي وحده يعني هذا هو
الحقيقه ثانيا بالديانات على كل ما بيقول
انه كان خلاف بين بدو غير صحيح الثوره
بتونس بدات ابو عزيز ياخذوا
يعني المساله الثورات هكذا تبدا كان فيه
واحد اسمه اه سعود السعيد هو زعيم اه جزء
من البدو ليس كل وهذا شبيه
كان كان سعود السعيد حال فما يفوت على
مضافه بدو ي لا يعلق السلاح في صدر مضافه
كانت الدوله عاملته سعود السعيد وجماعته
بمثابه عصا غليظه على الجبل انصار اه
باغنامهم جماعه السعود السعيد على ما حصل
الناس قامت فخامه الدوله وقفت مع اشكالات
وقفت مع سعود السعي فتحولت المعركه
بعدين تحولت المساله الى مساله طائفيه
يعني
ما هي النقاط انا
ما بدي اقول لك مين قصف قصف التحكيم سنه
الاثنين وثلاثين شهرا جدا اجرتها وكاله
الانباء بحرمانه سنه الالفين وثلاثين نشر
خبر وكاله الانباء منو جريده السفير
الاكيد
بعنوان اسرع حكم قضائي في تاريخ المحاكم
السوريه هو الحكم القضائي بشهر رمضان
بالالفين وثلاثه
مدينه المسيحيين والدروز بيجي فيه واحد من
زياره بمحله بيجي الشرطه يقبض عليه
بياخذوا لوين عالمحكمه خلال ساعه بيكون
نقاط على تدخين سيجاره
اول شيء
القضاه عندنا البعثيين كلهم
الموظف العادي نحنا شو بيكون بعثه فكيف
القاضي يعني نحنا بالجيش انا خدمت عسكريه
اللي
كيف قاضي يجرؤ ان ياخذ
ياخذ يعتقل مواطن عم بمحله ويحكم شهر سجن
شو صارت الدروز
الحالات الفرديه
هذا الموسم
الاقليات هذا
كيف يتعامل مع انا باحكي الان بشكل شمولي
انا سالتك سؤال من الذي قتل زعماء
الاقليات من دروس
يعطيك الصوره
في انا من قريه معارض اسمه بفضل الله حجز
سجن عشر سنوات مشهور السلام اول الثوره
بعد شهرين قتله السير بعد المعارضه كمان
المعوش بعد شهر
بعدين احمد الهجري
شغله هو رفض اصدار بيان يؤيد النظام ورفض
مجيء هذا الحوار
السويد الثاني في سيارته وبعدين
يعني شيخ الدروز احمد الهجري قتلوا
الامريكان نظام اخترع الطرقات الذكيه
بالسيد يعني ما في سياره معارضه ثلاثه على
الاقل
هذا اليوم
القادم النظام النظام لا يتعامل بمنطق
طائفي ولا بمنطقه الاقليه ناخذها على شغله
حماس حركه اسلاميه سنيه اخوان عندما
غادروا او طردتهم اسرائيل الى مرج الزهور
استقبلتهم سوريا بقرار من الرئيس حافظ
الاسد وكان الاخوان المسلمين وشكل انذاك
الرئيس حافظ الاسد اللجنه من عبد الحليم
خدام من 2 عبد الحليم خدام قال يمنع
استقبال حركه حماس لانها لانها لانها سنيه
هذا كلام في غايه الاهميه خليني
الاسرائيلي استقبل الرئيس بشار الاسد خالد
مشعل عندما طردته اسرائيل جميل كما استقبل
سوريا الحركه التحرير ال ال العراقي
كيف ترد على الذين يقولون ان النظام منذ
بدايه الثوره وهو يحاول دق الاسافين بين
الاقليات والاكثريه في السويد خطف
المخابرات العسكريه كل هذا السويدي يعرفون
المخابرات العسكريه خطفت خمسه عشر شخصا
على
عند وفيق ناصر هذا الاجرامي المجرم الكبير
هذا الارهابي الكبير
الفريق السويدي
اسمه موجود عندي
تدخل على كما قتل من اهل من جبل العرب
الشبابيه
ما مصلحه النظام مصلحه النظام
ان تكون كل الجماهير
ما مصلحه هذا سؤال انت تقول للمخابرات
العسكريه هي التي خطفت الدروس وان تكون
عند النصره دائما ماذا حصل في سد العين
بالمناسبه
يا دكتور يا اخي ال النظام يخطف الناس
ويبيعوا لجبهه النصره في معلومات الا ما
نفوت فيها يخطف ناس من السويد في واحد
المخابرات العسكريه مخابرات عسكريه وغير
العسكريه
اللي عم بقول لك مثلا اضرب لك مثلا اخترع
ونحكي فبركه جريده الاخبار اللبنانيه او
جريده الاخبار لانه هي مخابرات جريده
الاخبار اللبنانيه
خبر انه اجبار دروز ادلب على تغيير مذهب
اه اول شيء اجريت الاخبار سرقت صوره من
موقع افغانيه هاي الصوره يا ريت ياخذوها
موقعها موقع افغاني نساء افغانيات يلبس
يشبه الدرزيه وحطت كدليل انه ها الدروس
غيروا مذهب او تحت ال
لما جينا فرحنا ثانيا حطينا حطينا الضابط
الاساسي والموقع قام جريده الاخبار بحذف
الصوره والاعتذار عن ال
انا اقول لك انه انه نظام طوال الوقت
الاقليه بين الاقليه والاكثريه يريد ان
يقول لهم البعض السني سيقول لكم
هو اليوم ما يحصل انا مثلا اه خطف وكذا
والى اخره اليوم شو صار اليوم حكم يعني من
قله النزاهه ان نقول انه ها حكم الاكثريه
نظام كل الوقت اذا راح يصير
تعرف اول الثوره باختصار طلعوا مشايخ من
الجبل معروفه او زار بشار الاسد وطلبوا من
الطلب واحد قالوا له يا سياده الرئيس
مطلبنا هو انه اهل بلاد السويد المجيد
الجواب كان يحكي مع الدوله الفاطميه
النظام النظام فلذلك انا بس بدي اقول عن
مساله
اليوم
النظام
انا لانه مع الرئيس بشار الاسد هو ضمانه
لكل السوريين بكل طوائفهم وما شاء الله
وفي لبنان السيد حسن نصر الله ضمانه كل
اللبنانيين السبب والمسؤولين وحتى
المسيحيين وحتى من يعبد لا اله الا الله
كان المسيحي المسلم او غيره انا اقول لك
هذه المنطقه لا احد يستطيع ان يضبط ايقاع
ويتعامل معها بكل نزاع الا الرئيس بشار
الاسد
الاقليات عمليه الاقليات بالنسبه للنظام
هي بمثابه فلسطين فلسطين بين ال عن ضائع
بعد ما تكتبه النظام وخصوصا فلسطين اختراع
ان فلسطين ثاني اليوم تحت مسمى حمايه
الاقليات كله لانه بحاجه الى خرقه يرتكبها
عورته الطائفيه بدو يخبي دائما محتاج الى
خلق او فلسطين او حمايه الاقليات
النظام في الجيش اردنا ان هاشم وعبر
الطائفيه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر يعني المقدمه للشعب
السوري واللبناني رجال المقاومه باختصار
شديد خلينا ناخذ ها النظام يحتمل
بالاقليات
الاقليات
كل الشعب السوداني جدا اه هل تعتقد ان
النظام السوري ينتشر في الاقليات اربعه
وتسعين فاصله واحد نعم يتاجر خمسه فاصله
تسعه لا يتاجر لم يبق لنا الا شكرا ضيفينا
السيد شريف شحاده وال سيد ماهر شرف الدين
نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك
الحين ها هو فيصل القاسم يحيكم من الدوحه
الى اللقاء يعطيك العافيه
[موسيقى]